hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem live video hier auf kontrast und
zwar fragen sich jetzt bestimmt einige
bzw alle leute von euch hey warum kommt
ein video auf contractor nicht auf
meinem rad kanal lucasfilm das ist ganz
einfach so hey komm ich meine hände da
unten drin in dem kleinen bildschirm in
der kamera hellkuhl früh das ist ganz
einfach aus dem grund weil ich das ganze
mehr oder weniger verbinden möchte es
kam ja jetzt schon mehrere wochen auf
luca film kein video mehr das war
einfach weil mein mikrofon ist einfach
abgebrochen
deswegen musste ich mir ein neues
besorgen ich hoffe das geht jetzt mit
der qualität mit dass ein anderes ist
ich hoffe dass bis jetzt ein bisschen
stabiler von der quali sollte eigentlich
das gleiche sein aber ich versuche das
so bald zu behalten dass die qualität
durch nachbearbeitung gegen wieder die
gleiche bleibt und in der zwischenzeit
wo ich halt kein video machen konnte
habe ich mir natürlich so gedacht luca
filmt und contra zwei kanäle finde ich
jetzt nicht so geil eigentlich möchte
jetzt lieber als auf einem kanal machen
den dann macht das ja auch unter anderem
deswegen dachte ich mir konnten sonntag
ist natürlich sowie den astag habe ich
denen auch gefragt wer da nichts gegen
aber ganz einfach kontakt ist was
komplett anderes als den astag im den
astag marina immer so sachen somal news
dann mal dies mal dass ich mache
eigentlich nie so news im kontakt
sondern mehr so halt ich nenne das ganze
ja nicht mal kontakt ich sag nur das
sonntags immer ob kontrakt daniel epp
video kommt warum genau sonntags und
nicht irgendwie zwischendrin in der
woche lieber will ich zwischendrin der
woche einfach so machen wenn ich halte
mein video frei habe und einfach
dramatik in kein video hat sondern
irgendwie bock hab mich vor die kamera
zu stellen
aber das ist ganz einfach für die leute
die extra nur auf dem kopf sind hier am
start sind und mich nur live sehen
wollen dass die dann einfach kontrakt
nicht abonnieren müsste sondern einfach
nur sonntags auf den kanal contractor
gehen und dann einfach nur sonntags dann
da das real life video sich anschauen ja
im kontakt ich nenne das immer kontakt
ich werde die serie ja nicht mal kontakt
nenne ich besagte jeden sonntag wird
dann hier auf contractor video kombi zum
beispiel dass ich ein paar fakten
raushauen oder paar sachen raus habe die
ich überhaupt nicht mag oder eventuell
euro
kommentare kommentiere also ein
rückblick der woche mehr oder weniger
oder dass ich auch vielleicht mal ein
bisschen ein paar sachen draußen
schneide oder ein paar sachen einfach so
aufnehmen so spielfilm oder so keine
ahnung irgendwie sowas wird dann immer
mal so kommen und vielleicht aber
spontane sache das kann natürlich auch
mal sein dass der kontakt der sonntag
aussetzt man kann natürlich auch mal
sein dass das ganze aus jetzt werde ich
dann keine zeit habe allerdings werdet
ihr der früh genug auf facebook twitter
instagram mir habe ich gar nicht
informiert
das war eigentlich schon alles was ihr
wissen müsst also sonntags kommt ihr
ziel mal kein gaming oder eben etwas
anderes vielleicht auch schon aber auf
jeden fall kommt da ein mir live video
auf kernkraft also sonntags immer können
schön ausschlafen dann findet ihr hier
ein video gegen 14 uhr keine ahnung
irgendwann sonntags kommt jemanden video
luca film werde ich als zweit kanal
nutzen also für outtakes et cetera die
dann zu fast zu jedem real video werde
ich dann wahrscheinlich ein paar
outtakes machen die nicht mal unbedingt
witzig sind weil manchmal einfach nur
gestellt und irgendwie normal was
witziges anzupacken sondern einfach nur
da wo ich mich verhaspelt oder irgendwie
sowas und ihr haben dass man und das war
nicht der erste kontakt sondern mehr nur
seine info hier am ersten sonntag und ja